[Applause]
[Music]
let's start today's video with a
question which country would you say is
the u.s. is biggest a line is a Canada
they do see UK and what what about
Israel now this is not an easy question
to answer and it definitely depends on
who you ask
however there is a country which has
improved its alliance with the US a
great deal over the last few years it
has improved enough that it is for
Republicans the best friend of the
country unions biggest ally more so than
any other country I know it's not Canada
and though it's not the UK or Israel it
is Australia the country of surf
kangaroos and the Sydney Opera House
surprised well you shouldn't be
Australia is dear viewer the only
country in the world to afford with the
u.s. in all of their big Wars World War
1 World War 2 Korea Vietnam the Gulf War
Afghanistan Iraq and now also the
operations against Isis for the Pentagon
we could almost say that Australia is to
the USA what the score is to a movie
that at first might go unnoticed that
remove that music and you can see that
it's really something that's going to be
missed on January the 28th 2017 and
despite this all the lions Donald Trump
decided to hang up the phone on Malcolm
Turnbull Australia's Prime Minister not
just that though before he told him to
get lost and hung up on him Trump
accused him of trying to export
terrorists through the United States and
this was all just about a slight
disagreement that these two countries
had over 1,250 refugees well that's a
story that we're going to get into
another day yes this brief diplomatic
tussle might not seem like that much in
the grand scheme of things but it has
had a lot of consequences many
Australians are left wondering if it
isn't time to start cooling off the
relationship with the United States by
just a little
[Music]
so well naturally this is something we
started wondering as well it raises
questions like how important is
Australia for the United States and was
it really sensible for Trump's hang up
the phone on his greatest ally and what
kind of consequences is this going to
have for him well let's take a look
shall we
time for Asia it's probably not news to
you especially if you've been following
this channel for a while who else has
changed and both the political and
economic power centers are moving
quickly to Asia by 2020 it is expected
that more than half of the world's
economy and population will be located
in this continent and China is emerging
as a new superpower and well that's a
fact up until now a map of the world has
looks pretty close to this one well from
now on we're going to see things looking
closer and closer to this one as you can
see Europe is leaving the center of the
world and is taking up a position in the
corner all right so that's just a fun
comparison but we can't really deny that
the world is changing what tell us that
it's where you've been living this whole
time the 21st century it's going to the
Asia's century some things we've
discussed a bunch here a visual politics
that is why former US President Barack
Obama decided to bet strongly on Asia
and make this continent is top priority
for American diplomacy it was under
these circumstances that Australia
became such a valuable friend but how
close is this friendship between the US
and Australia well let's have a closer
look
[Music]
a big alliance in November of 2011
Barack Obama and Australia's prime
minister at the time Julia Gillard
finding military agreements which meant
a new era for military cooperation
between these two countries we could
always say that this new treaty started
a military friendship between the US and
Australia in fact let's take a look at
the description the New York Times wrote
about this agreement the agreement with
Australia amounts the first long-term
expansion of the American military's
presence in the Pacific since the end of
the Vietnam War but well what did this
agreements what did it really mean
well for starters thanks to the treaty
the US can deploy a fighting force of up
to 2,500 soldiers in Australia these
troops are from the Marine Corps and
they are able to quickly deploy in the
event of any conflict but don't think
that this is the end of things since the
collaboration between these two
countries has grown and grown it has
grown enough to become an essential
relationship for Washington it is not
just the Marines the United States wants
to make Australia the key home base for
their activities in both the Pacific and
Indian Oceans
[Music]
so now you're probably getting the idea
the US wants to have access to landing
strips situated in the north of the
country from here they want to be able
to deploy b2 and b-52 bombers they also
want to set up a large naval base near
Perth for their enormous fleet of
nuclear aircraft carriers and nuclear
submarines
[Music]
and there's more the United States is
also trying to locate and monitoring
centers and missile launch warning
facilities there too they even want to
rent part of the koko islands in the
Indian Ocean which are under Australian
sovereignty so you may now be thinking
what do you mean why would the United
States want to rent some random remote
islands in the Indian Ocean well the
answer is actually pretty clear the US
wants to locate their long-range
surveillance aircrafts and armed drones
on the koko Islands they also want to
use this archipelago as another
deployment center for their bombers in
case of war but wait because there is
still more the United States wants to
improve the integration between their
army and the Australian military so that
the two forces could work together
whenever needed now if you don't exactly
understand what the results of this
could be well do consider this in the
last few years Australia has carried out
a significant renovation of their
military equipment we're talking about
purchase contracts worth billions and
billions of dollars and the monkeys
there is quite a lot of American
material so it's a controversial f-35 is
an example Australia is committed to
buying 72 units which is going to cost
19 billion dollars this is a serious
amount of cash and we're talking about
the country with little more than 24
million inhabitants here so to a person
it's really a lot of money
[Music]
all right so now you've got to be
wondering why Australia right well
that's for several reasons first because
both countries are culturally similar
and as we've said before they fought
together many times
Seton's it's because Australia's
geographical position is almost perfect
it's situated between the Indian and the
Pacific Oceans and it is close enough to
the hot spots in Asia that the US could
carry out attacks and deploy troops
there quickly and last but not least
there's another important factor
Australia is an important energy raw
material and food supplier to China so
the Pentagon believes that in the event
of a conflict or tough tensions between
the two countries it would be convenient
to have control over Australia
absolutely well what about the other
side what do you be Australian swans
they basically understand that the US
can sort of be an insurance policy no
way to ensure their own security
however there are some voices who
disagree and these voices they seem to
be growing louder and so the Trump
hasn't helped with his whole hanging out
the same thing but Chinese alternative
now China is by far the largest trade
partner for Australia it is the first
destination for Australia's exports it's
the country of origins and many of the
immigrants coming to Australia and
besides there are more and more Chinese
people who visit the country every year
or who have decided to study that anyway
the Chinese mean a lot of money for the
Australians and well that has its
consequences a 2016 survey conducted by
the public policy group Lowy Institute
asked respondents to identify the
country that was more important to
Australia 43% chose the United States
and 43% China in 2014
48% had answered the United States and
only 37% had chosen China New York Times
and look under 45 year olds clearly have
opted for China and almost half of the
country's population believes their
country should keep some distance from
Trump's America pork eating and
important Australian ex Prime Minister
for example is one of the personalities
who thinks it would be better to try to
improve relations with China and let
relations with the United States cool
down a bit and pay particular attention
to how he explains his position the
Society of ours is a better society than
the United States it's more even it's
more fair we've had a 50% increase in
real incomes in the last 20 years
median America has had zero zero so now
Australia has made some kind of gestures
towards the Asian giant as an example
went by the way Washington didn't like
this at all the country decided to
participate in the Asian infrastructure
investment bank an institution led by
China whose aim is to increase China's
influence in the country the Australian
government itself has made it clear that
China is above all a source for
opportunities for the country luckily
for Trump though there are still many
things that protect his relationship
with Australia
[Music]
the American culture and the fear of the
Chinese dragon Australian and the US are
politically culturally and economically
similar countries they are so similar in
fact at an international level that it
could be argued that Australia is
nothing more than an extension of the
American lifestyle in Asia and the truth
is that a lot of Australians are pretty
pound to be considered that way whatever
happens I will not dull my affection for
the American people and the best of
American culture it was not raised in
America but I was raised in the American
Century I'm not yet ready to say goodbye
Lisa prior furthermore the United States
is still the largest investor in
Australia and investment that exceeds
500 billion dollars also the fact that
china is still a dictatorship is making
Australia suspicious many simply don't
trust Beijing's intentions in fact the
government has stopped many Chinese
investment operations that intended to
fine land in Australia so we can say
that it kind of all of indicates that
the alliance with the US will continue
but the Australians well there are very
practical people and they have made it
clear that they don't want to be
affected by a future hypothetical war of
power between China and the United
States so well that's what we think here
at visual politic and now we'd love to
know what you think do you think the
United States will despite Trumbo
carrying out the projects they had
planned to do in Australia or do you
think China will achieve more and more
influence in the country and most
importantly how would you feel if Trump
hung up the phone on your country's
leader so if you did enjoy this video
please do hit that like button and don't
forget to subscribe below and stay tuned
for new videos who put them out twice a
week also check out our friends of the
reconsider media podcast they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not
mine and as always thank you for
watching what are you a chance to get me
outta here with that jacket
[Music]
better than average